LAWRENCE CHANG:
Welcome to our session,
The Future of Apps and Search.
My name is Lawrence Chang
and this is Jason Douglas.
We are Google product
managers, and we're
so happy that you guys
are joining us here today.
So we have a lot to talk about.
It all boils down to just
a couple simple things.
How can you make
search-friendly apps
so that Google can help
drive installs and discovery
of your applications,
as well as engagement
of your applications?
So I'm going to start
off by talking about what
we think it is a
huge opportunity.
I'll talk about how you can get
app discovery through a Google
search, as well as how can
you engage users with your app
through app indexing
in our new API.
And then Jason's
going to come on stage
and talk a little bit more
about Knowledge Graph,
as well as our actions and
how that can help as well.
So if this looks good to you,
make yourself comfortable,
and stick around.
So let's get started.
Now the mobile app
ecosystem has really
taken off for the
past few years.
There's over one million apps
in the Google Play store,
and every year,
on average, users
are installing more and more
applications to their devices.
Now, as you all know,
it's getting harder
for your applications
to be discovered
and to reengage users.
We're seeing that people
are installing applications,
and then using them once,
and forgetting about them,
and then not using them.
So what can we do about that.?
Well, we think Google
search can help.
So let's take a quick
look at the web.
This year, the web
is on track to exceed
one billion unique host names.
One billion.
Now even at this scale,
search and search
friendly websites
are working together
to already solve this
big problem of discovery
and engagement.
And we think we can do the
same thing for search and apps
that are search-friendly.
And that's what's so
exciting to us about this.
It really feels like we're
just getting started.
And there are so many
things we can build on,
that we've already
done with Web Search,
and apply it to applications.
So let's start with
that discovery.
So I wanted to talk
about a scenario.
Last weekend, I was at the
California Academy of Sciences
with my family, and we went
to the Steinhart Aquarium.
Got to see the
Philippine coral reef.
We got to see some sharks.
And so I thought,
hey, it might be
cool to install some
wallpaper on my phone.
So imagine that I'm searching
for shark live wallpaper,
and you'll see in Google Search
results, application results,
right there, all
clustered together.
So we started doing
this last December,
clustering app search
results, and making
them more prominent in Google.
When you tap on any one
of these particular apps,
then you go to Play store,
and from here, very easy
to go ahead and install
the application.
Now we initially launched
this just for US English only.
And this year--
this week-- we're
really happy to say
that this feature is
now available globally.
So whether you're searching
for applications in Japanese,
in Spanish, in Russian,
or in other languages,
you're going to start
to see more application
results in Google Search.
Now how can you make sure you
get your application actually
shows up this cluster of
applications in Google.
Well, let's talk a
little bit about that.
So a lot depends
on your Play store
page for your application.
So this is where it might be
not intuitive to some of you.
So I asked Matt Cutts.
So Matt Cutts is the our
head of Webspam at Google.
So I said, what can
I tell you about how
to see if your content could
show up in a Google Search.
He told me to tell
you three things.
So here we go.
The first thing, basic tips.
Think about when a user is
looking for your application.
What are the words that
they're typing on their screen?
And just make sure that
some of those words
are in the description
for your application.
So very intuitive things.
Now number two, make sure
that your app's Play store
page is well-linked.
So as an example, if
you have a home page,
if you have a website
for your application,
and you have a home
page, just make
sure you're linking to your
Play page from your website.
Number three, don't
overdo number one.
Don't stuff your description
with all kind of keywords
and so on.
At the end of the
day, it's going
to harm you more
than it'll help you.
But these are some
basic rules of thumb
you could follow to make
sure your app can show up.
Now, we've been
working a lot on making
sure the right apps show
up at the right time.
But in certain
situations we're still
not triggering applications.
And so here's an example.
I actually have a
75-gallon marine aquarium.
And after going
to the Cal Academy
I realized, oh, my aquarium
is in terrible shape.
It's so dirty.
Probably because I've been
spending so much time on Google
I/O preparation.
So I want to do some searches
on aquarium maintenance.
And so if I do a query
in Google today, actually
I don't see any app results.
But what you can do, is if
you go to the search tools
and click on applications, then
you could refine your query
in the same way that you refine
your queries for images, and so
on.
And what you can do is,
you can refine your queries
for applications,
and you'll actually
see application results there.
And this also works
on desktop as well.
So if you're on a
computer, and you're
searching for applications,
you can use Search Tools
and actually look for
applications that way as well.
And we're spending
some time trying
to make sure we improve the
quality of the applications--
the ranking of
applications that show up.
And on desktop you also
have some additional tools
that you can use to
filter the results.
Now, we also are trying
to make it really easy,
if users have a specific
application in mind
that they want to find, to make
it easy for users to discover
and to actually install the app.
So if you search for,
Houzz Android app,
the Houzz application
is a great application.
All kinds of creative
ideas for home
renovations and decorations.
And maybe I want to figure out
how other people have displayed
their aquariums in their homes.
And so I search for
that Houzz Android app,
and now you'll see at the
very top of search results
an answer card.
Pretty prominent.
It says, here's the app.
Go ahead and install
it from Google Play.
It makes it very easy for you
to go ahead and install it
from Google Play.
So let's talk next
about app engagement.
Now app engagement, right
now, is mainly app indexing.
How do you get deep links
to your applications
from Google Search results.
And so let me show you a
demo of that right away.
So, a couple of weeks ago, I
saw some really interesting
headlines about sharks.
There is this super
predator of the ocean,
and scientists basically had
tagged a great white shark,
a nine-foot shark, off
the coast of Australia
and they were studying it.
They were tracking it .
And suddenly, one day, it look
like something had basically
chased down the shark
and devoured it whole.
So scientists are
somewhat baffled.
Like, what could have happened?
Is it a giant squid?
Who knows?
So for years, they weren't
sure what this-- what happened.
So they dubbed it
the super predator.
So let's do a search for
the super predator here.
Do a query for the
super predator.
And here you go.
Here's my search results.
Now, let's actually check
out the first result.
It happens to be a website
from the Smithsonian channel.
You click on this, and you
see that there's actually
a show about the super predator,
"Hunt for the Super Predator."
And you can find out some
more information about that.
Further down, you'll
see, oh look at that.
Here's an application result
for the Huffington Post.
It's an application I have
installed on my phone.
How do I know it's an
application result?
Well, look at the green
text below the title.
We call this the visible
URL line actually.
And so for websites,
you'll normally
see a URL there-- a web URL.
In this particular
case, we've replaced it
with the name of
the application.
We've also added the app icon.
So this tells the user, look
if you click on this result,
it's going to go directly
into the application.
So let's do that.
So I tap on the link.
And it deep links directly
into the Huffington Post app.
And see, you could read
some more information
about this bizarre mystery of
what happened to the shark.
And so on.
Now, if you want to go
to the website instead,
you can tap on the open
Huffington Post link here,
and you would go to
the website instead.
And so here, we're actually
opening up the website.
Oops, Let me do Always.
And there's the website.
So it's possible, still, for
you to get to the website
if you would like.
Click here.
Let me go back here.
Now, conceptually it's a
very subtle visual change
from our previous deep linking
UI, where the title link now
goes to the app, but
functionally it's
pretty significant.
Though a lot of users
tend to use that title
link quite a bit.
So we expect this will
drive much more engagement
of your application
than our previous UI.
As you scroll through the
results, you'll see, oh, look,
there's web results.
And oh, look, there's
another app result.
And this one's for IMDB-- IMDB
app that I have installed.
So I don't think any more.
Like, do I want to
search for this in IMDB,
do I search in the
Huffington Post app,
you just search from Google.
And very quickly we can jump
into two apps, three websites,
all with the same query.
So, it takes the
burden off the user,
and it makes a
seamless experience
between apps and the web.
Now, the other thing I wanted
to point out about this,
is that philosophically,
there's a big difference.
So for the first time,
we're treating apps
that you have installed
on your device
with the same level of
prominence as websites.
So this, we think,
ultimately is going
to have a pretty
big impact on how
we can drive engagement
of your applications.
So what do you
need to do in order
to participate in app indexing?
So far, we're very happy
to had the opportunity
to work with a number of
early adopters for this.
We announced this
past December, working
with a handful of developers.
And we want to thank them
for all their hard work
and for working with us on this.
It's helped to smooth
out the rough edges
and give us the
ability to support
a wider variety of applications.
Now we'd also like to
thank everyone else
for your patience, because
we know that some of you
have been waiting for this.
There's been a lot of interest.
So thank you for your patience.
And we're so happy that we were
able to announce yesterday,
at Google I/O, that now app
indexing is open to all Android
developers globally.
So if you follow
our guidelines--
[APPLAUSE]
If you follow our
guidelines, then we
can get deep links to your
applications in our search
results.
So how do you do this?
What are the steps
you need to take?
How do you make your app
more search friendly?
So let's talk a little
bit more about that.
Three steps, basically.
Three simple steps to get
started with app indexing.
The first one, your app needs
to support deep linking.
Second, we ask
you to verify what
the official website
is of your app.
And third, you
just basically need
to specify, what are the
links that your app supports.
So I will talk a little
bit about each of these.
First, with deep linking, you
have a couple of options here.
You can choose an HTTP
scheme or a custom scheme.
By HTTP scheme what we mean
is, if your app supports
the same web URLs that
your website supports,
that's what we mean
by HTTP scheme.
If you want to create a
completely different scheme as
well, you can do that as well.
And we refer to that
as a custom scheme.
So let's talk about
we need to do.
First, your Android
manifest file.
You need to update that.
Now, you find the main
activity of your application,
and you have to add
an intent filter.
Now the intent filter needs
to have a couple of settings.
You need to specify that
the action type is a view.
And you need to specify
the categories are
browsable and default.
And you need to do that
for whatever scheme
that you choose.
Now, if you want
to use HTTP based--
like a web URL scheme,-- you
need to specify the data scheme
as HTTP.
And then your host as-- at
example.com in this case,--
your host would be
your web domain.
And then whatever path
you have beyond that.
Now if you want to
support a custom scheme,
you specify the scheme.
In this case it would
be example://gizmos,
your scheme would be example,
and your host, in this case,
would be gizmos.
Now, as I mentioned
before, the intent filter
is specified for a
particular activity.
So whenever the
operating system sees
that someone's clicking
on a link of these formats
that you've just a specified,
it'll launch this activity.
And so let's look
at that activity.
If you don't add any code
there, then basically any
link that you have
would launch-- anything
that fits those patterns
will launch the activity.
But if you want to deep link
to something specifically,
and you want your app
to do something special,
then you need to add some code
to actually parse the intent
to do the right thing.
So here's just a
very simple example.
You could basically get
the intent, get the data,
parse it, create a new intent,
and start another activity.
And you could do this to kind
of figure out where app goes.
Developers do this
in other ways.
Some developers create what they
consider a trampoline activity.
So the intent comes
in, and they actually
send it to the cloud,--
to the back end,--
figure out where they
want to send the content,
and send a message back to
the app, and from there,
have the app do the right thing.
So a lot of this depends on
the architecture of your app
and how you want to do this.
And we won't go
into too much detail
beyond that at this
particular point in time.
But that's what it takes to
support deep linking your app.
And this is one of the
most important steps
to make a search-friendly app.
The second step.
This step is what I think is
the easiest step of them all.
And I think it's
the easiest thing
that anyone has asked you to do,
I think, at all of Google I/O.
And so, you could do
it now if you want.
If you wanted to-- some
of your laptops out-- you
could actually do this now.
So what do you need to do?
Just go to the Play
console when you sign in.
And after you sign in,
go to the application
that you want to sign
up for app indexing,
or participate in app indexing.
And then you look for the
Services & API section.
On the Services & API
section you scroll down,
you look for app indexing
from Google Search, and then
the Verify Website button.
All you do, you click the
Verify Website button,
then you type in
the domain, and then
if you have a
separate webmaster,
then you basically wait.
If you're your own webmaster,
then you go to Webmaster Tools,
you sign into Webmaster Tools.
You'll get a message
from the Google Play
store asking you to
approve this request.
All you do is
accept the request.
And that's it.
As simple as that.
Now, what's kind
of neat about this
is if you choose web URL
so as the linking scheme
for your app, based
out of HTTP, then we
can actually start
the indexing process.
So this is a shortcut to
get the indexing started.
Well, how does it work?
We've indexed your website.
So we know the web URLs
that your website supports.
So we basically take those links
and we start the app indexing
process.
And so this is a way
for you to get it going.
So if anyone asks you,
have done app indexing,
you can say yes, we've done it.
But, you should still
follow up with step three.
Step three regardless
of if you support HTTP,
or if you support custom scheme,
we still recommend you do it.
And if your using
a custom scheme,
this is something you
have to do to let us know,
what are the links
that your app supports.
So you have a few options here.
I'm going to talk
about the first two.
I'll talk about the
third one later on.
You an add your links
to Website markup.
You can add your link
to your site map.
So very quickly, it's
one line of code.
And all the web pages that you
would want deep link to an app
with.
And so let's talk a
little bit about this.
Now, on this line of code,
we ask you to specify link
rel="alternate" tag.
And it's because
conceptually, it
has the closest meaning
to what we want.
It basically says, there's
another representation
of this particular document.
You're on a web page.
There's another version
of this document,
and it happens to reside
at this next address.
And so, the other
thing is it asks
you to specify the address
in a single string.
And this is important
to us because when
you think about
the web, everything
is linked with unique
single strings.
So it's much easier
share things and so on.
So we wanted the
unique single string.
And when you think about
linking and mobile,
as you probably already
know, it's a bit of a mess.
All the operating systems
do things differently.
So if you want to create a
unique address to a document
or page with an
application, you should
have to start with
what is the operating
system you're talking about.
So in this case, we
specify Android app.
Once you know it's
Android, well then,
what's the unique
identifier for applications.
It's the package ID.
So you have to specify the
package ID for the application.
And then, from here,
whatever scheme
that you chose before, you
specify this scheme-- if it's
HTTP or your custom scheme--
and then the subsequent path.
Now we like this
format because we
think it's very, very efficient.
We're taking some steps
is to standardize this
through [INAUDIBLE] and Jason is
going to talk a little bit more
about that later on.
If you want to
use site maps, you
can go and add a similar line,
basically, to your site maps.
And then you can add it
to your existing site map
and you would update it
through Webmaster Tools
just as you do today.
So we've just talked
about the three steps
it takes, and at this
particular point in time,
app indexing can start.
Now, just like the
web, and web indexing,
it's possible there are
errors within indexing.
So, we've added
some tools-- we've
created some tools--
to make it easier
for you to diagnose these
errors and to fix them.
So they're in Webmaster Tools.
You sign into Webmaster Tools.
You go to the website--
the web domain
that you connected
through your app.
I look for the
Crawl Error section.
In the Crawl Error
section, you'll
see a new tab, Android app.
And right there, if
you go below that,
you'll start to
see links to URLs
that are having some issues.
And what you could do is you
could tap on these links,
and we'll actually
show you a pop up.
We helped you try to
figure out what's going on.
We explain what we
think the error is.
And we give you
some recommendations
for here's what we think
you can do to fix the error.
Now, a couple of things
I want to call out.
Testing on mobile can be
tricky, especially when
you're testing these
deep links and so on.
So we've added a couple
of tools to make it easier
for you to check these
things on your phone.
You click on the app URI,
we'll show another pop-up.
We'll give you a QR code.
You can take any standard QR
code reader, scan the QR code.
A web page will open up,
tap that link and that will
let you just get
into the app directly
for the URI of interest.
Now after you've fixed--
the issues are [INAUDIBLE],
you can mark as fixed, and that
gives us a queue that we should
schedule and start
indexing again.
And so these are the steps.
You've added deep links
to support your app,
verified the website,
published app deep links,
and, on an ongoing basis,
you should periodically
check if there's any
errors and so on.
So let's talk about
the App Indexing API.
This is new.
We announced this
yesterday at the keynote.
And there's a couple of main
benefits to the App Indexing
API.
First, the early adopters
that we talked to, some of you
said to us, you know what,
it would be really nice
if we can specify the
links to our application
through the app itself.
So we don't have
to use a website
we don't have to use site maps.
So the App Indexing
API lets you do that.
Now secondly, there's
another benefit.
And this benefit
speaks to how you
can get additional engagement
to your application.
So let me show you a demo.
So I want to show you-- We were
talking about the California
Academy of Sciences earlier,
and let me do a query for that,
and what you can see
here is on device
suggestion, an auto-completion
for the Google Earth app.
The Google Earth app has
implemented the new App
Indexing API.
And as I'm doing a query
in Google Search app,
it offers an
auto-completion for this.
And it shows it because
I've spent some time playing
with the Google Earth app.
This is something I've
seen before in the Google
Search-- in the
Google Earth app.
So now what happens
is, when I actually
tap on this deep link-- it's a
deep link-- to the Google Earth
app and it goes directly to the
California Academy of Sciences
tour that I had seen before.
So as this is
playing I'll explain.
One of the cool things
about this building
is they have a living roof.
So when you look
at it from the top,
it looks like it's this field.
They took sod, they laid
it with all the sod.
And then they took native
plants and planted it.
And this has all kinds
of cool benefits.
It keeps the building
cool, et cetera.
So this is a neat feature
if actually go visit.
You should go to the
roof and check it out.
And, of course, as you
actually dive in there,
you'll see this isn't
an actual field.
It's actually a
building, et cetera.
Here's another example
of the App Indexing API.
So now, if you're
going to go visit
I would recommend checking
out Patxi's Chicago Pizza.
My wife and I were from
the midwest, from Michigan,
and we love our Chicago pizza.
So if you're going to go,
you can check this out.
Now, it's Zagat's app.
I've been to this page
in the app before.
And they've also implemented
the App Indexing API.
And so as you can see, I did
a query for Patxi's Pizza,
it showed up as an on-device
auto-completion, tap on it,
and deep link right back
into the application.
And it's one of the--
even Zagat thinks--
it's one of the best
restaurants near the California
Academy of Sciences.
So that's an opportunity-- it's
something you can check out.
So, now Zagat is a
pretty good example,
because they implement
app indexing already.
So what that means is they
have deep links in our search
results to the app.
Now what the App Indexing
API lets them to do
is to get additional
engagement by adding deep links
to their app from
auto-completions.
So it's an additional way
you can drive engagement
for your application
through Google search.
Now, the API is new.
It's available in Google
Play Services 5.0.
And the auto-completion
feature will
be available in an upcoming
version of the Google Search
app rolling out soon.
So that was a recap of how
you can use Google, create
a search-friendly application
to get additional discovery
from Google, get
engagement through app
indexing and the
App Indexing API.
And now Jason's going to
talk a little bit more
about some cool things to
do with Knowledge Graph.
JASON DOUGLAS: Thanks Lawrence.
All right.
So you've heard how Google can
surface deep links to your apps
directly from search results.
And this is made possible
because Google is now
maintaining an index of the
deep links in your apps,
just as we've always maintained
an index of the deep links
in your websites.
But Google also has another
index, a special one
for the people, places
and things in the world,
and we call this index
the Knowledge Graph.
And we use the Knowledge
Graph, and it's
understanding of
the relationships
between real world
entities, to power lots
of great new features in search.
So, for example,
the Knowledge Graph
is what helps Google
answer a query,
like Imagine Dragons tour,
with not only the web results,
but an answer card
that conveniently
summarizes the
events in the tour.
So where do the details
of this tour come from?
Well, they actually come
from the band's website.
They added structured
data to their pages
that actually tell Google what
the specific events in the tour
are, so that those events can
then be added to the Imagine
Dragons entity in
the Knowledge Graph,
and finally used as answers
to users' queries in search.
If you look really
closely, you can
see that the structured
data uses vocabulary
from schema.org.
And this is useful because it
means that not only can Google
understand it, but potentially
others can as well.
Because schema.org is
a collaborative effort
between many search engines,
and lots of other folks
as well, to establish
a common way
to describe things
with structured data.
OK.
That's great.
But what does this
have to do with apps?
Well, we've started
to add actions
from apps to the
Knowledge Graph as well.
And this is made possible by
combining the structured data
approach I just
showed you with events
with the new world
of app indexing
that Lawrence was telling
you about earlier.
And we've started
this with music,
and I'd like to
assure that you now.
So let's see.
Too many technical
things going on here.
All right.
So since we were talking
about them earlier,
let's try Imagine Dragons.
Get this out of the way.
So while it was nice to
hear about their concert,
it would actually be nice
to listen to them right now.
Well I can.
So you see here a list of the
music apps I have installed.
And they can play
Imagine Dragons.
So let's try Spotify.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So it's just that easy.
A single tap, and it
starts playing my music.
OK
So going back--
now I actually have
a lot of music apps installed,
so to see the full list
I could expand it.
And what's important here
is that Knowledge Graph
will actually remember
whichever service I pick.
So the next time it will
actually be first in the list.
So let's try iHeart
Radio this time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So it's super convenient.
It's a really great way to
get quick access to my music.
But what if I want to
discover new music?
So, for example, my
daughter is pretty young
and she's just to
the age where she's
starting to learn
about pop music.
And her friends have been
trying to convince her
that there's really only one
act that matters, Katy Perry.
And so here she is.
Now my daughter is
also the age where
it's all about
videos on YouTube.
She watches them all the time.
So I'm pretty sure
that's what she'd pick.
But you notice that iHeart
Radio is actually now first,
because that's what I
had picked the last time.
But I also know for a
fact that she has probably
seen all of Katy Perry's videos
on YouTube, too many times
for my taste.
Oops.
There we go.
But she can also use
the Knowledge Graph
to browse other
artists and see what
other people have searched for.
So for example-- again
she's pretty young
and probably doesn't
even remember
when Lady Gaga was big,
and might be curious.
But she can also
flip through, see
lots of other related
artists of people
who searched for Katy
Perry also search for,
and for each one
of them quickly be
able to get to their
YouTube videos.
There you go.
What'd I do with the clicker?
Ah, there it is.
OK.
And there we go.
So now I have instant
access to my music apps
whenever I search
for music artists,
or browse for music
artists, on Google.
So we launched music
actions last week
with the following partners.
And we'll be adding
more partners
and more kinds of
actions over time.
So please stay tuned.
In the meantime,
since many of you
are developers, let's talk
about how this actually works.
So the key thing
that we need to know
is specifically which deep
link plays Imagine Dragons
automatically in
Spotify, or iHeart Radio,
or any other service.
So the way a
service enables this
is with structured data that
tells Google exactly that.
What is the specific
deep link that
enables the listen action
for the music group,
Imagine Dragons.
And you can see that deep link
format uses the same as what
you saw with Lawrence earlier.
And in fact you can
sort of think of this
as, this is the deep link
for that Shuffle Play
button on the screen.
This extra data is
necessary to tell Google
exactly what that button
does, and what intent to fire,
and what it accomplishes
for users, essentially.
So how is it different
from that link tag?
Well it's not, really.
Like I said, it's
just an extension.
The link tag format is
great if all you need to do
is connect a view
in your website
to a view in your app, which
is perfect for search results.
But if what you're
trying to communicate
is something a little bit more
sophisticated, like an action
button, then this extra
data is very helpful.
So that's the App Actions in
the Knowledge Graph, which
is made possible with the
new world of app indexing.
So we talked about a
lot of features today.
We've covered a lot of ground.
But there's really
a common thread
that runs among all of
it, which is that Google
is a search engine
for apps, too.
So this means that if users are
looking to discover new apps,
they that can do
that with Google.
If there's a search
result that can
be served by an
installed app, Google
will take them directly to it.
Or if they're just
trying to find something
that they saw
recently in an app,
they can see it in suggest.
Or to help users accomplish
a task, actions from apps
can surface directly
in the Knowledge Graph.
So to get started, as
Lawrence was describing,
you go to the Play
store and sign up.
And there's a lot
more information
on
developers.google.com/app-indexing.
And there's also I/O byte videos
for both app indexing, as well
as schema.org actions, and
even events in Knowledge Graph.
And I guess there's also
a Q&A session later today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LAWRENCE CHANG: I
think we can do it now.
Right?
JASON DOUGLAS: Oh.
There's also the booth.
But, yes.
We'll take questions now--
LAWRENCE CHANG: We can
take questions now.
JASON DOUGLAS: --if people are--
LAWRENCE CHANG: Sorry.
We'll do to the 10
minutes of questions.
And there's Office Hours.
JASON DOUGLAS: Office hours.
That's what I meant.
Not Q&A. Q&A is now.
Office Hours are at 1:00.
Is it?
1:30.
Sorry.
LAWRENCE CHANG: So if
anyone has some questions,
feel free to stick around.
Sure.
Why don't you start?
JASON DOUGLAS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: My
question is, are you
going to be opening
up the Music App
actions to anyone
who wants to use it?
And if not, how would one
become a partner to use those?
JASON DOUGLAS: Well you can give
me your card after the show.
At the moment, this is a
pilot with specific partners,
but we will be expanding
over time as I said.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Maybe I'll find you
after the-- thanks.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Hi.
Yeah.
Why don't we go over here.
AUDIENCE: This looks
like a great solution
for managing hundreds
of apps on devices.
Are you integrated with
Android Wear at this point?
So you can do the app
discovery and deep links
through Android Wear?
And launch from there?
Or Android Auto?
The session we just came out of?
JASON DOUGLAS: Well,
so any-- I think
as you've seen in a lot of the
demos-- most of these platforms
all use Google Search
in various ways.
And Google Search
is Google Search.
And this expands
across all of it.
LAWRENCE CHANG: But yeah.
We don't have a demo that.
And it would make a
lot of sense for us
to do something like that.
AUDIENCE: On your config
file, I saw Music Group,
and you said that you index
people, things, and places.
Is there a canonical list
of groups that we can find?
Obviously we can't
just make them up,
because they have to
come from your indexes.
JASON DOUGLAS: Well so there is
a canonical list in Knowledge
Graph, but actually just saying
that was a listen action, even
though it was a string
of Imagine Dragons.
Google has a lot of
smarts and can figure out
which Imagine Dragons
that you mean.
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
your configuration
there, you said
this is a type of Music Group.
So I imagine there are a list
of all these different types
of things.
Maybe it's not a music group.
Maybe it's a conference.
Where is a conference
is an event.
Where do I find that list?
JASON DOUGLAS: schema.org.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Perfect.
Thank you.
JASON DOUGLAS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Out of the four methods
that you showed,
where apps can
interact with search.
So in your demos, most of
it was on the search bar,
does it actually work if
I search an app on Chrome,
let's say?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Yes.
It does.
AUDIENCE: All the
four methods work?
LAWRENCE CHANG: So if you
go to search in Chrome.
google.com in Chrome.
You have to be signed in.
If your signed in,
you will be also
deep linked to applications
from there as well.
AUDIENCE: And also
the app indexing?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Yes.
Exactly.
So when we index
your application--
AUDIENCE: No.
Not the app aren't indexing.
Sorry.
The Indexing API.
The third method you said.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Oh.
That one, right now, no.
It's through the
Google Search app.
You'd be searching through
the Google Search app
to get those [INAUDIBLE] there.
AUDIENCE: OK thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Romain from France.
I was wondering, do
you plan to expand
the deep linking integration
to iOS apps as well?
LAWRENCE CHANG: So today,
when you talked about some
of the discovery features
earlier on, where
you can look in the
search tools for apps,
we already show iOS
applications there.
And we're focused, naturally,
right now an Android,
to make the best
experience we possibly can.
But our Google users are on all
kinds of different platforms.
And that's really
important to us.
But right now, we don't
have anything else
to announce today.
But it's something
we understand.
AUDIENCE: So once
we do the search,
you expect the app should
show the data immediately?
That's one of the rules?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Sorry.
Ask the question one more time.
AUDIENCE: If I do a search.
If I am linking
it to an article,
say, in my application.
And I click that, so
lets say for IMDB.
I search for a movie.
I click on it.
It opens the IMDB app
with the movie directly.
Now all this is
possible, because there's
an API for a
particular data value,
like for the movie in
which I can [INAUDIBLE].
LAWRENCE CHANG: Right now,
we're generating the snippit
automatically for you
on search results.
In the case of the
App Indexing API,
where there's an
auto-completion,
you do not specify
the title as metadata.
AUDIENCE: No.
But what if the data
needs to come as a bundle,
and I don't have the
data with me immediately.
Then can I give some
sort of user experience
in terms of saying that
the application needs
to be downloaded first?
Or that content needs
LAWRENCE CHANG: Oh.
In the application?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In the application.
So say I search for an article.
Say the shark article.
Now you showed the
Huffington Post thing.
That is a single article which
just came out from a website.
Or I pulled it from an
API and it displayed it
on the Android device.
But now, if it's
a magazine, it's
multiple articles
that are [INAUDIBLE]
into a single magazine.
So I cannot just get
a single article.
I need to--
LAWRENCE CHANG: You
would need to create
a separate deep link, probably
for, each of those articles.
Right now.
Then it would have to map,
basically, to your website.
If your website is
doing something similar.
AUDIENCE: But not every user
would have it immediately.
They would still
need to download
that entire set of articles.
LAWRENCE CHANG: If I
understand correctly,
I think, your app is going to
pull down the articles, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
It's a bundle.
It needs to pull down
the entire bundle.
And then I deep
link each article.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Right?
AUDIENCE: But how
does the server
know that this particular bundle
is downloaded for this user.
LAWRENCE CHANG: I don't
think we need to know.
All we need to know is that,
for us, all we need to know
is that the user has
your application.
Does that make sense?
And then, if the user
has your application,
and we've indexed the
content application,
and we have indexed the
content in your web,
and it's showing up in
Google Search results,
then it's up to your app
to basically parse out.
Once we send the user to
you, with the particular link
that you told us,
it's up to you to have
your app do the right thing.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but I think there
are some certain
rules that have to be
followed for the
app [INAUDIBLE].
LAWRENCE CHANG: Sure.
Let's take this offline.
Lets talk after this, and we can
spend some more time on that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Craig.
This question might be a
little premature as well,
but I guess my question is,
given that, right now, the app
has to be installed,
do you guys have
any plans to use this
for promoted placement?
Or for suggesting
apps to install
that the user hasn't
installed yet?
LAWRENCE CHANG:
Whell we do have--
we can start with the
app discovery features
that I talked about first.
So if you're searching
for applications,
we'll surface cluster
results there.
And we also have
ad formats as well.
So our ads team
recently announced
that they have a--
because you can imagine
the same thing would
make sense to deep link
from an ad to an application,
the same way it makes sense
to deep link from search
results to an application.
And so that's also something
that-- they're out in beta
right now.
There's a mobile
engagement campaign ad
format that you can go
search for it on AdWords,
and they're looking
for sign ups.
So that's another
possibility right now.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi my name is Lou.
So if your app
requires authentication
how does Googlebot crawl it?
LAWRENCE CHANG: So,
that's a great question.
Right now, we don't.
But we have something
in the works--
and this was actually
briefly mentioned
in the keynote
yesterday-- and this
is something we've
definitely looked at,
because we understand that
in mobile, a lot more times
the application developers
are asking users
to sign in before
they can see anything.
Whereas on the web,
it's a little less.
So we definitely get that.
And one of the things we
have rolling out soon,
is if an application
supports Google+ Sign-In,
then you don't have
to do anything else.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about this
in the coming months.
But this was already
announced yesterday,
so I think I can talk about it.
So that would
solve that problem.
So as long as your app
supports Google+ Sign-In.
There is another
answer to that as well.
Some developers have basically
changed the architecture
of their app as well.
And so, when you get a
deep link to your app,
if the user hasn't
signed in, they still
expose a little bit of the
snippet of the content.
And above that,
they'll ask the user
to sign in at that
particular point in time.
And that's another possibility.
Of course, anyone
could do that now.
AUDIENCE: Because I've
noticed that Googlebot
has been crawling a lot
of my app in particular,
and it's been puzzling
how they've been doing it.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Well,
one of the things
that happens that maybe
might be surprising,
is that there is
things that you're
app is doing-- a lot of things
are basically-- whatever
resources that your app is
pulling from your servers.
In order for us
to index your app,
that all needs to
happen in order
for us to see what's in the app.
But sometimes it's
a little surprising,
if you have [INAUDIBLE]
resources and so on.
But it's not us doing
anything with that.
It's literally, you
give us the links,
and that's what we look at.
We try to open that
link in your app.
But if your app is
pulling resources
from all kinds of
different APIs and so on,
it has to happen in order
for us to see that content.
But we're not doing anything.
In terms of anything
else in the data,
it's just getting
the data to your app.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have the
same content on the web
and on the app.
For the deep linking I could use
the same URL for the website.
I could use a new HTML URL
for the active linking.
LAWRENCE CHANG: That's right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or I can
use the custom scheme.
So what's the best practice
here, for the indexing?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Well I
think we would recommend
you can use-- I do the same
web URL-- the same HTTP URL
scheme-- for both the
website and the application.
AUDIENCE: So the
problem I can see
here is that if you tap
on the website name,
then you would go to the
app directly already.
So how does Google
distinguish that?
Will I get two results on
the Google Search result?
Or would I get just one?
Because it's like
the exact same URL.
LAWRENCE CHANG:
So right now, what
would happen in
our search results,
is if the user had
the app installed,
then it would have been
next to the application.
Your title link would
go to the application.
And then the link on the bottom,
would go to your website.
But it would be the
same link that's true.
But the difference
is, that link is
the one that could be
used to go to the website.
So the top link we're
specifying a package
ID, which is Android app.
We're launching your app.
So it's unambiguous.
The link on the bottom,
the user can click on it
and basically they'd
have to set a preference.
If they have a browser,
in their browser
they would have to specify I
want the browser to open this.
And then it would just open
the browser all the time.
Go to your web page.
JASON DOUGLAS: It's also
based on whether the user has
the app installed.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Yeah.
Right.
If the user does not
have the app installed,
it will just to go to website.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
LAWRENCE CHANG: But you could
use custom schemes as well.
And you can do that as well.
AUDIENCE: So do you mean
the best practice is
using the custom scheme?
LAWRENCE CHANG: No.
No.
I mean the reason
why I would recommend
HTTP URL is for, it can help the
indexing process start sooner
for you.
So that's one of the reasons
why I'd recommend it.
But we support both.
So there are some
situations where you may--
the other reason
actually-- is if you
want linking across
Android, it's also easier
to use HTTP schemes.
If you want the link
to show up somewhere
else in another Android app,
and someone to click on it
and go to your app, then HTTP
is better for that as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So the HTTP schemes allowed
in the manifest right now
don't really have
complicated Regex's.
So we'll have something where
we allow deep linking to like
/shop, but then the website
adds something at like
shops/policies that
we don't have yet.
And we haven't found a
good way around that.
I was wondering if
app indexing will
have all those same problems?
And can you recommend
any way around?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Actually I think
we do have something for you
there.
We just published this in
our guidelines yesterday.
You're going to be able
to specify some more
details in a noindex XML file.
And this is new.
You can check out our
guidelines for more details.
But in your Android
manifest file,
you can specify a link to
an additional XML resource.
In this resource file,
you could specify,
don't index these particular
patterns, these links.
And it could be a much longer
list of patterns and so on.
And I think you can get
as detailed as you want,
effectively.
And so that way,
when we look at it,
we will know that the
app doesn't support this.
So give that a try.
AUDIENCE: That sounds perfect.
What's that coming out with?
LAWRENCE CHANG: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: When is
that available?
LAWRENCE CHANG: It
should be available now.
AUDIENCE: OK
LAWRENCE CHANG: So go ahead
and look at our guidelines
and, to be safe,
give us a few weeks.
But this is part of what
we're announcing at I/O.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering what you
guys make of the App Links
open standard that Facebook
put out a little while ago,
and if you're planning
to leverage that at all,
or if it's just a
tangential project.
LAWRENCE CHANG: So
I think right now,
in terms of are we using
any of that and so on,
we're not using any of the app
links, the schema or anything
like that.
So we're focusing
a lot on the things
that we've talked about today.
Android already,
with Android intents,
lets you do a lot of the
deep linking and so on.
And so anything that we're doing
to deep link to apps, actually,
any of you could be
doing, also on Android.
But with that, I think
we are working more
with schema.org right now, from
a standardization perspective.
So we are definitely
thinking that hey,
we should be working with
more companies on this.
But that's currently
the path we're taking.
Anything else you would add?
AUDIENCE: I guess,
specifically, in order
to do some sort
of cross platform
like iOS deep linking, in
addition to Android deep
linking, are you thinking about
doing anything like App Links?
Or is that a different
tactic you're going to take.
LAWRENCE CHANG: So I think
this goes back to iOS question.
And I have, I think, the same
answer for the iOS question
there.
That we recognize that iOS
is an important platform.
We recognize we have
users there as well.
And App Links does propose
some solutions there.
Is schema.org-- do we have
anything on schema.org yet?
For iOS?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAWRENCE CHANG: Do
we know-- schema.org
it's Microsoft, Yahoo, Bing.
JASON DOUGLAS: Yeah.
In fact, Microsoft has
been using the schema.org
schema for Windows deep linking.
So.
We'll see.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Does that
answer your questions?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
LAWRENCE CHANG: But, in
general, we think yeah,
we're focused a lot, right now,
on making a good experience
from our search results
and search experience,
but we're generally
happy, though,
at the way the momentum
is going in the industry.
Right I mean more
applications are
supporting deep
linking, which is great.
That's one of the
most important things
in creating a
search-friendly app.
And to the extent that people
do that with app links,
in general, that part
of it is quite positive.
We think the momentum
industry is good.
JASON DOUGLAS: OK.
I think we're--
AUDIENCE: I work
in gaming, and I
was wondering if
you guys have seen
any good-use cases of deep
linking and app indexing
with games, in particular?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Yes.
Yeah, I think there are
some really, really cool
applications that
we can do for games.
I'd love to talk to you
more about that afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAWRENCE CHANG: OK?
Anything else?
Are we--
JASON DOUGLAS: Yeah I
think we're in the red.
LAWRENCE CHANG:
We're in the red.
Are we OK?
JASON DOUGLAS: Or is
there not a session next?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: If the user
is in search mode,
and they press on a deep
link, and it takes them inside
of the app.
Is the app switch becoming the
equivalent of the Back button
for a web browser?
How can we make that more simple
for them to go back and forth?
Because a search
seems like they have
to iterate and
change their query.
JASON DOUGLAS: Didn't
they show some stuff
about that in the Keynote?
Or no?
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAWRENCE CHANG: Well, sorry.
I think, in the
case that I showed,
I went to Huffington
Post, hit the Back button,
it should have gone back
to the search results.
I think that--
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
working on anything
to extract the action intent
to run that in the background
inside of the Google
Search query results?
So you could press
play on Spotify,
the Spotify will have
them play in the browser?
JASON DOUGLAS: I'm not
sure I'm following.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Like a
background intent.
Like iOS was working
on extensions.
So you can make a call
and have the Spotify app
play in the background.
Without having to
[INAUDIBLE] the browser.
JASON DOUGLAS: All
of the action stuff
is using the intent system,
so the various capabilities
of the intent system might
be leveraged over time for--
LAWRENCE CHANG: Right now,
we're opening your app.
Maybe the last question.
AUDIENCE: Real quick.
Thinking about an app as equal
to a website, I wasn't clear.
Would the search
result ever show an app
that you haven't installed
yet on your device?
Well, it does today,
actually, through--
So if you search for
applications, we already do.
It's through your Play store.
AUDIENCE: But not in
the organic results.
Just in the app pack?
LAWRENCE CHANG: Well, I
think about them as similar.
They're organically
ranked, and they show up
in our search results.
So we do have that.
So you can find
applications content there.
But I will say, it's
still very early,
and there's a lot
more we can do.
So I think we could
potentially hit
a lot more of these
interesting cases.
Probably the ones maybe
that you're thinking about.
JASON DOUGLAS: That's one of
the nice things about having
the equivalence between
the website and the app.
The user hopefully gets
the best experience,
whichever state they're in.
AUDIENCE: What if you only
had an app and no website?
Would that ever get indexed?
LAWRENCE CHANG: So
right now, your app
which show up if you have
a game, for instance.
Like when you're
searching for Google,
we'll surface your game.
And then, I think the Google
Earth example is a good one.
If you start using
the app indexing API,
that's one way we can
start driving engagement
of your application--
of your game.
And Google Earth
doesn't have a website.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
JASON DOUGLAS: Well thank you
guys, so much, for your time.
Appreciate it.